by bringing the entire Marvel Cinematic
Universe together to face off against
the universe returning bad guy Marvel
appears poised to make all the money in
the world when Avengers infinity war
hits theaters the film looks huge and
everything we've seen so far as fans
more than eager to see more but why
exactly should this one knock our socks
off from the ante upping villain to
fundamental changes in store for core
Marvel heroes here's why we think
infinity war will blow us all away the
next staff beta the entire MCU has been
framed around the idea that an insanely
powerful villain by the name of fan OHS
has been pulling the strings behind most
of the universe's problems he's popped
up in the Avengers and guardians of the
galaxy to cause trouble sending lackeys
ahead of him in an effort to acquire the
ultra powerful Infinity stones
after years of setting him up infinity
war will finally place Sano's front and
center and co-director Joe Russo has
said that he's hoping to make a Darth
Vader for a new generation with another
Avengers sequel arriving in just one
year he might remain a key player in the
MCU even after the dust settles from an
infinity war Asgard go boom the first
two installments of the Thor franchise
were arguably some of the weakest in
Marvel's lineup but all that changed in
2017 under director Taika Waititi thor
ragnarok reinvigorated the series and
added a sense of humor the mainstream
MCU never knew it was missing it also
featured some of the biggest character
growth yet for Chris Hemsworth Thor he
lost his hammer his father his eye and
when Asgard was destroyed his home
despite the losses Authority stronger
hero co-director Anthony Russo has said
he feels Thor might be the most
interesting character heading into
infinity war after his past has been
torn away from him
the one-eyed Thor will have to overcome
his losses in Ragnarok and find a new
hammer to take on the most dangerous
Phil in the heroes have ever faced
you know mad bro one of the biggest
changes for the MCU over the past few
years is that when we pick up the action
in infinity war
Captain America might not even be
Captain America anymore the first
glimpses we've gotten of Steve Rogers
shows him sporting a beard and the
shield and in his most recent autograph
signings cap actor Chris Evans has been
using the name Nomad a moniker Rodgers
took up in the comics after becoming
disillusioned with his role as Captain
America there's no word on whether the
big screen version will follow the same
track but Captain America Civil War
The Avengers apart it'll be interesting
to see whether infinity war can bring
them back together
I am teenage groots there's no denying
the role Groot has played in the success
of the Guardians films and bringing him
over to a mainline Avengers film as a
moody tree teen adds yet another bit of
geeky goodness to infinity war motion
capture artist Terry notary who provided
the movements for Groot said the
character will be coming of age in
infinity war which should make for one
interesting subplots to go along with
all the world ending stakes I am Spider
fans got a brief peek at the new
spider-man suit at the end of spider-man
homecoming and the trailers for infinity
war show Peter Parker will definitely be
taking advantage of the upgrade when
Fano strikes if you pay attention to the
Lego toy tie-ins for the film though we
might just be seeing another new design
for Spidey the iron spider suit that
Tony Stark made for Peter and the comics
what better place to pull it out than in
Marvel's biggest movie ever but Condor
takes center stage black panther blew
the roof of the box office and made two
charla an instant icon for superhero
fans
luckily they won't have to wait to see a
lot more of the world of Wakanda every
trailer and teaser for infinity war has
made it abundantly clear that black
panther on makanda are going to be a
huge factor there on full display with
plenty of interactions between T'Challa
and Steve Rogers joint size Marvel as if
it weren't already obvious infinity war
is poised to be Marvel's biggest movie
to date it's bringing a-list stars and
key supporting players from every solo
Marvel franchise loading the film with
everyone fans have come to know and love
over a decade of the MCU
but it doesn't just combine the
guardians of the galaxy and the Avengers
into the same storyline it brings them
into one single fights Anthony Mackie
who plays Falcon as said it'll feature a
scene with a mind-boggling 40 heroes on
screen at the same time making the
massive brawl in Captain America Civil
War look like a tussle on the playground
by comparison Marvel has flexed its
blockbuster muscle time and again over
the last decade but infinity war looks
like it's really ready to throw down the
gauntlet no pun intended end of an era
with infinity war putting a cap on the
first 10 years of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
it's hard not to start looking ahead at
what Disney's pending purchase of Fox
could mean for the future if everything
pans out Marvel may look to reacquire
the rights to their other two biggest
teams the Fantastic Four
and the x-men it stands to reason those
characters will eventually be folded
into the MCU in the same way that
Spiderman was brought in after Marvel
Studios cut a deal with Sony fans hoping
for a sneak peek and infinity war will
likely be disappointed though Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige has made
clear that any potential purchase will
not impact the studio's current state of
productions lined up through 2019 which
include both infinity war and
disentitled sequel that slow roll is
probably a good thing considering this
movie is already looking too general
dozens and dozens of characters as it
stands thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out this cool stuff
we know you love to
[Music]